[Musique]
pour notre dernier reportage de la série
lithium on va vous parler de la voiture
pour vous dire que la voiture c'est un
diable avec un moteur à essence et qu on
est tous coupables mais à quelque part
si on veut réduire drastiquement nos
émissions de gaz à effet de serre et
faire face à l'urgence climatique
on va peut-être de vous questionner sur
le rôle de la voiture et pas seulement
rencontre avec quatre experts
[Musique]
house erreur sur le web mais schumi on
veut régler une question en partant est
ce que ça existe une voiture zéro
émission on va être loin de mode de
transport zéro émission avec la voiture
électrique parce qu'elle n'est pas zéro
émission à la construction elle est pas
héros émission au recyclage elle n'est
pas héros émission pour les
infrastructures sur lesquels on roule
même au temps mon téléphone les pois
zéro émission est beau et électriques
qui a été produit tout ce qu'on produit
un impact peut avoir sa voiture pour
aller s'acheter une peine de l'ommegang
série
on peut pas dire que le projet
écologique
avant même d'être entré dans une salle
de montre les autos électriques et à
essence ont une dette environnementale
pour les construire folie bénigne du
transport et donc de l'énergie et pour
ça il ya des émissions de gaz à effet de
serre des pas mal de conséquence sur
l'environnement la construction d'une
voiture électrique nécessite plus de
métros que celles de voitures à essence
donc une plus grosse date sur la ligne
de départ c'est lors de l'utilisation
que la voiture électrique sera moins
polluante selon une étude faible dans le
contexte du québec parce qu'on utilise
l'hydroélectricité est une énergie
propre il va falloir rouler 85 mille
kilomètres avec une voiture électrique
pour qu'elle devienne un meilleur choix
environnemental dans d'autres provinces
du pays où l'on utilise des combustibles
fossiles pour produire de l'électricité
la dette peut être encore plus longue a
remboursé
dans notre studio aujourd'hui dominée de
villeneuve et professeur en transport et
mobilité à l'université laval on lui a
donné rendez vous dans un simulateur de
transport en commun à québec
la
droite
est ce qu'on peut dire qu'une voiture
électrique c'est du transport durable
ben là je pense que la réponse est
clairement non on a oui - de giresse
c'est tout toutes les autres composants
problématiques de l'indépendance
automobile l'étalement urbain qui
continue qui nous force à faire des à
élargir justement les autoroutes pour
aller toujours de plus en plus loin qui
fait qu'on soit déplace toujours de plus
en plus tout ça ça change pas la voiture
électrique est à la voiture thermique à
un moteur à combustion ce qu'elle avait
à potins c'était la cigarette dans les
deux cas ok quand on utilise on a une
meilleure conscience ça peut lui pas
juste dire qu'autour de nous ok mais
dans les deux cas ça vient pas rêver
notre problème de dépendance la voiture
qu'elle soit thermique ou qu'ils soient
électriques il ya plein d'autres
problèmes associés qui ne vont pas être
réglée du fait qu'on change de
technologie c'est la deuxième plus
grande cause de deux micros plastique
dans les océans c'est les pneus des
autos
continue de rouler électrique ou drôles
et thermique on continue cette pollution
à chaque point de vue environnemental
oui c'est un constat d'échec toujours à
québec ont rejoint olivier ducharme
c'est un essai est qui a écrit sur la
place des autos dans nos vies son livre
dénonce le rôle central compris la
voiture dans notre société
[Musique]
dans les années soixante dix il y avait
pas loin de 1000 personnes qui habitait
ici dans la paroisse notre dame de la
paix il fallait faire de la place pour
les autos toujours plus nombreuses on a
évincé les résistants démoli les maisons
et construit l'autoroute
dufferin-montmorency
aujourd'hui on est dans une espèce de
faire un vague qui devenu un symbole de
l'automobile la destruction manque
d'autorité dans l'île est-ce que ça
arrive souvent dans l'histoire du québec
où on va donner préséance aux véhicules
plutôt que l'habitation pas juste au
québec et en amérique du nord en général
et en europe après ça a été tout le
mouvement des rénovations urbaines que
eu lieu après la deuxième guerre
mondiale que fait que la plupart des
grandes villes dans lesquelles
européennes ont subi des rénovations
urbain de la construction d'autoroutes
urbaines l'élargissement des rues l'une
des grands chantiers qui ont été ouverts
et un hacker que les rebelles ont pris
possession le plus des villes pourquoi
développe-t-on les vélo québec est ce qu
on les développe pour ses habitants ou
pour ces voitures se fait surtout pour
les voitures c'est sûr tout
développement économique les autorités
servent à son cerveau tout à fait à
l'habitation l'habitation arrive par la
suite les débats y ont été construites à
cause de conscience d'autoroute non pas
le contraire
[Musique]
c'est bizarre c'est vraiment bien dans
un cimetière ya comme des hommes perdus
mais c'est très troublant
est ce que c'est une mauvaise impression
de penser que les voitures grossistes au
québec il ya vraiment une une obésité
croissante du parc de véhicules c'est on
avait beaucoup les véhicules qui étaient
allongés avant là on a vraiment pris en
hauteur et en largeur très imposants ça
prend quand même plus de ressources pour
construire ces véhicules là même s'ils
sont électriques à
batterie ça consomme encore beaucoup de
ressources et plus les véhicules sont en
groupe les occupe de l'espace donc ça
augmente le niveau de congestion il va
mal ça consomme plus d'énergie il faut
aussi dire que c'est pas parce que les
véhicules sont plus gros qui sont plus
occupés mais quand on regarde les
statistiques à travers le temps le taux
d'occupation des véhicules diminue aussi
donc on a des véhicules de plus en plus
gros et de plus en plus visible donc
j'aime beaucoup dit que si nos routes
sont congestionnés si en raison
principalement du vide on transpose 8
[Applaudissements]
et transporté du vide ça coûte cher
chaque année on estime que les québécois
vont dépenser 20 mille dollars par
famille dans leur voiture l'entretien et
les sens c'est le deuxième poste
budgétaire des familles
on dépense plus pour nous au taux que
pour une épice
collectivement au québec le taux mobile
représenterait une dépense de 43
milliards de dollars chaque année les
véhicules restent stationnées 23 heures
sur 24 c'est hautement inefficaces comme
dépense monétaire mais pas une
entreprise qui investiraient dans un
actif qui resterait inerte 23 heures sur
24 est-ce qu'on va la bonne solution aux
citoyens lorsqu'on lui dit changer votre
véhicule à essence pour un véhicule
électrique
malheureusement on ne fait que vendre
une petite partie de la solution même si
on arrivait à tous remplacés demain
matin on aurait toujours les autres
problèmes d'étalement urbain de
congestion routière de manque d'exercice
physique d accidents de la route qui
vont arriver tout autant avec des
voitures électriques avec des voitures
essence et aujourd'hui on parle surtout
d'électrifier les transports on change
on parle pas de transformer notre
approche à la mobilité et c'est ça qu'il
faudrait avec l'argent que les québécois
met dans les véhicules individuels on
aurait de quoi se payer des systèmes de
transport collectif des trains à haute
vitesse mais pour couvrir le québec
évidemment ça serait un changement de
paradigme très difficile à faire avaler
du jour au lendemain mais il faut
progressivement aller vers ça pour
pouvoir vraiment atteindre notre
objectif ultime qu'est la
carboneutralité en 2050
[Musique]
nos experts parlent de transformer la
mobilité selon eux ça passe
obligatoirement par l'investissement
massif dans les transports collectifs et
aussi en rendant la vie plus facile à
ceux qui choisissent de ne pas se
déplacer en voiture
mais à quoi ça ressemble une société qui
mise tout sur le transport en commun
dominés gré ne va habiter en suisse un
pays qui a fait ce virage ou plutôt qui
n'a jamais pris le virage de la voiture
est ce qu on est accro à nos voitures
oui oui mais je te dirai me tuer moi
aussi le cash partie du québec j'en
avais un char je les vends du primo bien
d'avion pour les femmes au doctorat en
suisse mais jamais en suisse jamais en
50 ans je me suis ennuyé de mon char
si on fait l'expérience d'un bon système
d' alternative à la voiture peut-être
qu'on va s'apercevoir qu'on a n'a pas
tant besoin et que ça parce qu'il ya
aussi un coût énorme qu'on oublie
toujours le coup de posséder une voiture
c'est énorme pour les ménages pas tout
le monde qui peut saper une ou deux
autos et quand on en a pas mais on
souffre du fait que l'alternative les
offres alternatives sont pas bien
développé on a comme besoin d'avoir un
auto pour être inclus dans notre société
c'est aussi un problème lié à
l'automobile it et qu'on va pas régler
avec la voiture électrique coûte encore
plus cher à acheter que la voiture
thermique prenez quelqu'un de chicoutimi
ou de rimouski qui souhaitent développe
se déplacer autrement qu'avec une
voiture c'est pas facile c'est pas
facile parce qu'on n'a pas mis en place
de bonnes options je te donnerai la
comparaison entre trois rivières et
lausanne hawking trois rivières et
lausanne ces deux villes deux cent
trente sept mille habitants évidemment
c'est difficile de transposer dans une
ville suisse au canada qui on n'a pas la
même densité sait pas exactement le même
territoire mais dans la ville de
lausanne on s'est doté avec le temps
d'un réseau structurant de transport en
commun alors que c'est paule ka à trois
rivières il ya un système d'autobus
cette eau rivières mais le réseau
structurant on revient assez les
autoroutes et les rues mais ce n'est pas
le cas à lausanne donc dans cette ville
la taille similaire à trois rivières il
y a deux lignes de métro tous les
autobus qui passe en ville sont
électrifiés et ils sont en train de se
doter d'un troisième lignes de métro et
devenir votre ami la voiture est pas de
dominante dans le paysage et ça fait que
quand on regarde les statistiques bien
on voit que population égale à lausanne
les citoyens ont fait 122 millions de
déplacements en transports en commun en
2019 à trois rivières ils en ont fait 3
points 4 millions
une grosse différence il ya des façons
de se développer qui sont pas toutes à
l'automobile mais il faut mettre
l'argent à bonne place ici la majorité
de nos investissements transports c'est
dans notre réseau routier
[Musique]
où
piano l'accent dans leur processus de
changement de comportement il aimerait
ça les conditions sont pas suffisantes
c'est pas si on leur donne un
financement des places en loges de john
hicks dollars du parti ne financent plus
d'approcher son lieu de travail donc si
on avait les estives pour encourager les
bons comportements onfray certaines
manning il faut arrêter de penser que
quelqu'un est un automobiliste ou un
styliste
solo c'est quelqu'un va être multimodal
aujourd'hui je me déplace en auto parce
que puis demain va être en vélo puis la
pression des transports en commun aux
transports en commun dont vous vraiment
que les gens gagnent des compétences
pour utiliser l'ensemble i mode c'est
pas une jour au lendemain vous je me
déplace finalement de tout
c'est pas comme ça c'est vraiment la
notion d' été raisonné dans sa mobilité
c'est de considérer les options de faire
le meilleur choix
[Musique]
la science nous dit que l'on devrait
diminuer la taille du parc automobile
pour atteindre nos objectifs
il y a 6 millions de voitures au québec
et la tendance est à la hausse la
question de la diminution du parc de
mobile est absent six côtes gouvernement
du québec elle n'est même pas mentionné
et le ministère des transports n'a
aucune cible de diminution du nombre de
véhicules
les politiciens doivent avoir un message
qui plaît et donne des bonus aux gens
ils n'y vont toujours avec du côté des
carottes jamais du côté des bâtons la
voiture étant tellement associé au
bonheur personnel à la liberté au
confort que si on leur dit il va
peut-être falloir sortir de votre
voiture allait vers l'autobus et bien ça
serait perçu comme étant une régression
par les électeurs je blâme autant les
politiciens qui ont pas le courage de
d'articuler un discours positif autour
de la réduction du parc automobile mais
il faut aussi blâmé les la population
qui semble ne pas avoir la maturité pour
comprendre ce nécessaire changement de
paradigme
au final le tout électrique c'est la
continuité stop pour ça que c'est si
facile à vendre comme projet devant le
défi du changement climatique
reste maintenant à voir si on fera le
choix de changer de modèle ou simplement
de moteur on a le problème des
changements climatiques
il ya des coups qui sont associés à ne
pas répondre à ces changements
climatiques on n'a pas le choix il va
falloir la trouver l'argent j'en ai
trouvé une face il ya dix milliards de
dollars sont prévus pour faire un tunnel
qui n'ira pas dans la bonne direction
renault lâche faisons des interviews
dans d'autres villes petites et moyennes
mais on en a des solutions c'est dans
dix ans avec ce qu'on connaît des
changements climatiques mais les défis
qu'on note on voit vraiment intelligent
d'avoir pensé qu'on pouvait pas
continuer sur ce système orienté sur le
véhicule privé nos enfants vont nous
trouver stupide temps ils vont être
close par qui vont être forcés en yvon
l'étranger j'aimerais que ce soit plus
facile aujourd'hui mais
c'était du programme penser qu'on peut
continuer à faire ce développement qu'on
puisse qu'on peut continuer en pensant
que ce mode de vie là va fonctionner
[Musique]